yo the uh origins of the mozzie thing
i had somebody told me stop me if i'm
wrong or right but somebody said it's
because you you had did a project with
someone he had a problem with nah
that's not the reason why he started he
did a project with somebody i had a
problem with it
oh yes okay yeah it wasn't
it wasn't me so it wasn't you copy copy
someone asked me
somebody from you've heard that before
like i'm not the first person to bring
this
wrong way okay but i heard it the wrong
way okay okay
someone asked me from his way
to do a song with me and i asked him
about it
and he told me yeah it's good you could
do it i can't
you know i'm saying but ain't no problem
but you can right so i feel like
it the respect could have been mutual
the same way because you asked
yeah like he was there when the person
asked me with this song yeah i didn't
know him like is it like so like
you can show me the same courtesy i got
people from richmond san francisco la
whatever like if i hang with somebody
these are my my boys in l.a right
somebody hear me from l.a to do it first
i'm like bro you know them
they're good you go right right right so
that's just that that's just kind of
that's what protocol was but at the end
of the day the person they did the album
with
in the [ __ ] up situation and and
all this [ __ ] happened over a dolphin
that's crazy over a crackhead
over there
again i'm saying like i ain't mad i'm
not upset like
ain't no shade like do y'all thing
whatever we don't we don't
it's 20 20 there's enough [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on i'm getting too much money bro
i'm still
japanese foreign still [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
i also feel like what's going on in the
world like there's like there's not like
like you know
a lot of people should probably put [ __ ]
aside that ain't that you know yeah like
we don't have to
talk like they don't got to be it was a
time before i didn't know you i was
straight so i don't
it's almost like yo people don't got to
worry if you guys run into each other
i don't know at least on your end i
don't know oh that's fair
i don't i don't i can't say that because
i don't know the vibe when when it
happens
you know what i'm saying that's what
you're saying as in music wise bro i'm
not tripping
as in like worrying about you making
songs or whatever but
i don't know you might be turned up when
you see me or i might be turned on i